another basic proof technique is called
proof by cases in which we prove
something by breaking it up into pieces
that are easy to prove but that together
cover all possibilities let's look at
the explicit simple example from
computer science here's a Java logical
expression way to decipher this is that
the double vertical bar means or in Java
and the double ampersand means an end in
Java so this is a conditional test and
if test that is the guard on a bunch of
code to be executed if this test comes
out to be true
let's read the test if X is greater than
0 or if X is less than or equal to 0 and
Y is greater than 100 go ahead and do
the code that's in there indicated by
the vertical dots we're going to assume
here that x and y are variables that are
declared to be of type float at a point
or real number or integers for that
matter ok now what I claim is that this
code can be improved and if it's
rewritten in the following way namely if
X is greater than 0 or Y is greater than
100 so the claim is that these two hunks
of code if I just replace this test
which has three components that require
an extra step to evaluate in some cases
by this code the programs are going to
behave exactly the same way and
therefore it's just more efficient and
easier to understand ones one step
faster if I replace this longer
expression by this shorter expression
now how do I argue that these two pieces
of code are going to behave in exactly
the same way you come up with the same
final output they won't behave exactly
the same because want to be faster than
the other
but they're going to yield the same
results ok let's consider how these two
behave in two cases the first case will
be that the number X really is positive
that it's greater than 0 what happens
then well the first test above in the or
to be true and that means that the whole
or expression is true because we're
natural or anything at all it comes out
to be true and you go ahead and execute
the code that follows likewise the
second expression starts with X greater
than zero or so it comes out to be true
so in this case if X is greater than
zero both conditional expressions will
allow the code that follows them to be
executed and then because they both
evaluate to true okay the next case is
that X is less than or equal to zero
let's see what happens then well in the
top expression since X is less than or
equal to zero that first expression X
greater than zero maybe what if it's
evaluated returns false and same thing
in the second expression the initial
test X greater than zero returns false
now one of the things that the way or
works is that if you have an or of a
bunch of things if the first thing is
false you ignore it and just proceed to
the other things to see how they come
out so what that means is that in both
of these expressions since the first
test in the sequence of things that are
being ORD together came out to be false
I can just ignore them the code is going
to behave as though after the false was
detected is just going to behave in the
same way that the rest of the test says
to behave well in the top case the
expression to be checked now is that X
is less than or equal to zero and Y is
greater than 100 but what do we know
well X is greater or equal to 0 and less
than or equal to 0 in this case so this
test comes out to be true and we have
something of the form true and
something-or-other
that means that the net outcome of this
expression it depends entirely on the
something-or-other that is it depends
entirely on whether Y is greater than 0
because the X is less than or equal to 0
and so this expression can be simplified
it's going to behave exactly according
to whether or not Y is greater than 100
so look what I've just done I've argued
that in this case both of these test
cards actually like
why is the test y greater than 100 which
is they behave the same in this case as
well so what I just figured out was that
in both cases all these two expressions
yield the same result which means and
the only possible cases are that X is
less than zero or the X is greater than
zero or likes X is less than or equal to
zero so in all cases they're the same
and we're done that's why it's safe to
replace the upper complicated expression
by the lower less complicated expression
so in general as I said reasoning by
cases breaks complicated problems at the
easier subproblems which is what we just
saw there wouldn't be clear how to prove
that these two things were equivalent
but I chose those cases and it made each
case or easy to figure out that the two
things were the same now the truth is
that there are some philosophers who
worry about reasoning by cases for kind
of subtle reasons they're called
intuitionists and here's what bothers
them with let me illustrate there's a
million dollar Clay Institute question
one of a dozen corso questions that are
considered to be the major open problems
in various disciplines of mathematics
and one of the disciplines of
mathematics is complexity theory in
computer science computational
complexity feeling this question is
known as the P equals NP question and
we're actually going to talk about a
fair amount in just the coming few
lectures but for now it doesn't matter
what it means well I'll tell you what it
means P stands for polynomial time and
NP stands for non deterministic
polynomial time I'm not going to define
non deterministic polynomial time but it
would be momentous if those two things
were equal and everyone expects that
they're not equal but no one knows how
to prove that so the million-dollar
question is is P equal to NP yes or no
and you get a million dollars for
settling this question now I claim that
in fact the answer to this
is on my lecture table and I will show
it to you in class tomorrow